Перший політ за два роки. Найбільший у світі серійний пасажирський
літак Airbus A380 вилетів з іспанського аеропорту Теруель
до німецького Франкфурта.
Невдовзі після початку пандемії авіакомпанія Lufthansa
зняла з експлуатації літак A380.
Так само вчинили й багато інших авіакомпаній у всьому світі.
Деякі з літаків відправили на зберігання в Теруель -
відомий як "кладовище літаків".
Здавалося, це була смерть для аеробуса, який споживає багато палива.
Адже, щоб приносити прибуток, він має бути повністю заповненим.
Але тепер той факт, що він вміщує понад 500 пасажирів,
знову став головною перевагою.
Літаки А380 повертаються.
Цього літа Lufthansa відправить у небо щонайменше
шість таких аеробусів.
Як ви можете собі уявити, це дуже складний процес.
З іншого боку, це необхідно, оскільки кількість пасажирів
збільшилася неочікувано і в короткі терміни.
Також виробники літаків відчувають труднощі з поставками
нових літаків в короткі терміни.
Хосе Молінер відповідає за те, щоб літак можна було вивести
з глибокого сну у будь-який час і повернути в експлуатацію.
Зараз він і його команда працюють над другим гігантським
аеробусом компанії Lufthansa.
Після того, як за час пандемії тут законсервували 13 аеробусів,
Молінер не думав, що вони коли-небудь літатимуть знову.
Ми не знали, що буде далі. Ми не знали, як довго цей літак тут пробуде.
Ми ніколи не думали, що він коли-небудь знову літатиме.
Ми дуже раді, що він нарешті підніметься в небо.
Але перш ніж негайно злітати знову, їх потрібно розконсервувати
і ретельно перевірити, щоб вони були придатними для польоту
- як зовні, так і всередині.
Хосе Молінер пояснює, що два роки глибокого сну негативно
позначаються на високочутливій техніці літака.
Тож відновлення його роботи вимагає великих зусиль.
Як бачите, мої колеги знімають усі пломби, кришки двигунів і шасі.
Знімається вся герметизація з дверей.
На це потрібно 2500 годин, це 4 тижні роботи.
Цим займається близько 40 людей. Потім ще 4 тижні підуть
на додаткове технічне обслуговування. Тож загалом треба 8 тижнів,
щоб повернути цей літак до експлуатації.
Зліт у Франкфурті. За штурвалом пілот Маркус Іленфельд,
який піднімає A380 на висоту 5 тисяч футів
- це приблизно 1500 метрів.
Щоправда, поки що лише на симуляторі.
Інструктор Річард Ленц перевіряє здатність пілота керувати літаком
у погану погоду чи в разі пожежі на борту.
Справа в тому, що через пандемію Маркусу Іленфельду
скоротили кількість льотних годин.
Через це його ліцензію Airbus призупинили.
Кілька тижнів тому її поновили.
Я був дуже щасливий. Це був "мій" літак - я літав на Airbus з 2014 року.
Мені довелося зробити перерву на два з половиною роки,
і я дуже за ним скучив.
Тепер інструктор Річард Ленц має якнайшвидше повернути за штурвал
якомога більше пілотів. Адже на початку пандемії Lufthansa
вирішила повністю відмовитися від A380.
Тож, нині кваліфікованого персоналу бракує.
На даний момент у нас є дванадцять пілотів, які можуть керувати A380.
Для такого літака, як A380, треба приблизно десять екіпажів на один маршрут.
Загалом потрібно знайти понад 100 пілотів - буквально за місяць.
Це доволі складний виклик.
Тим часом у Теруелі в Іспанії перший A380 авіакомпанії Lufthansa
готовий до зльоту. Річард Ленц і його другий пілот Матіас Спуде
полетять на ньому додому.
Хвилюючий момент - пілоти сідають за штурвал літака.
На початку пандемії вони обоє доставили кілька гігантських
аеробусів сюди, до Теруеля.
Це як повернутися додому знову…
Я дуже сильно прив’язаний до літака.
Все залишилося таким, як три роки тому.
Бортовий журнал за 2020 рік. Березень 2020 року.
Ми не здогадувалися, що нас чекає попереду.
У журналі немає нічого про коронавірус.
У кабіні пілота Ленц знову перевіряє бортові системи.
Він досі не може повірити, що повертає літак до Франкфурта.
Везти його сюди було дуже сумно. У мене справді був грудка у горлі,
коли ми припаркували літак. Це було справді гнітюче.
Атмосфера була, як на кладовищі. Сьогодні тут кипить життя.
Над літаками працюють, і ми точно не єдині, хто забирає їх звідси.
Настрій чудовий.
Пілоти летітимуть назад зі зниженою швидкістю.
Оскільки деякі технічні перевірки ще не завершені, шасі потрібно тримати зовні.
Переліт до Франкфурта займе вдвічі більше часу,
ніж зазвичай - понад 4 години.
Сінгапурські авіалінії відновили рейси з цим аеробусом
кілька місяців тому. Багато пасажирів, які проходили реєстрацію
у Франкфурті, свідомо вирішили летіти саме літаком А380.
Він величезний. Наскільки я знаю, це найбільший пасажирський літак у світі.
Він повинен бути дуже стабільним у повітрі. Я спілкувався з людьми,
які літали на ньому раніше і казали, що це приємний досвід.
Ми з нетерпінням чекаємо цього.
Зазвичай я боюся літати, але сподіваюся, що на такому великому літаку
все не так погано. Він дуже стабільний,
і ти ледве помічаєш, що знаходишся в повітрі.
Літак готують до рейсу в Сінгапур. На нього завантажують
бортове харчування для близько 600 пасажирів.
На верхній палубі - просторі місця для пасажирів першого і бізнес-класу.
А це - технічний ангар авіакомпанії Lufthansa.
У лайнера А380 перевіряють шасі за допомогою технології "Gear Swing".
Щойно розпочнеться літній графік польотів, цей найбільший пасажирський літак
відправиться в Північну Америку:
перші пункти призначення - Нью-Йорк і Бостон.
І поповнить лави інших заново запущених A380.